give me mr. commissioner Hogan please go
ahead you have the floor
thank you very much at the end of the
last council I didn't think that I'd be
here again today but this is the way it
is but I understand that matters are
progressing to the extent that we will
have a vote in the European Parliament
on the 27th of November in relation to
the new commission but I want him faith
by talking about the fact that this
could be my last date with Fish Council
Minister leppe has given a very
comprehensive overview of what happened
at today's council meeting so I'm just
going to make a few brief comments about
the points that we discussed this
morning we had this question of the
future of the CIP focused this time and
the issue of Environment and climate
ambition and I did express my concern
about the idea of a single common
dedicated share of funding for
Environment and climate purposes which
could have the unintended consequences
of leading to a lower level of
environment and climate ambition and
this is something and that we have to be
mindful of and to ensure that it won't
happen because the outcome of this cap
reform must be credible around the green
architecture because this is the way in
which we will ensure that farmers are
part of the solution in relation to the
environment and climate matters and it
also helps to maintain and justify their
income support in the European Union
taxpayer either side of the lunch break
and we discussed the different
transitional regulations because we now
have to transition to 2024 to generally
2022 in relation to the c.a.p reform
proposals it's clear that we will not be
able to agree these matters in time for
a 1st of January 2021 to give member
states the time to be able to draw up
the strategic plans and to have the
transition to the new regulations we all
know that we need to complete this work
as swiftly as possible the two
regulations the first one has to do with
the transfer of money from one pillar to
the other and the second is more
fundamental about ensuring that we have
the necessary full amount of money
based around the rural development
program and direct payments for 2021
many delegations made the point that
there are technical issues which they
want to tease out and my services are
available to help in this regard in the
afternoon we discussed three a or b
issues in particular apical shore at the
request of hungry rice from my animal at
the request of Italy and males from
Ukraine at the request of Poland I
recall the levels of support that were
available to the a P culture sector and
these tend to entry's significantly
under the new CAPM FF proposals country
the frames of some particularly some
vocal critics in the NGO world the
number of beehives in European Union is
actually increasing the number in 2018
there were more than seventeen point
five million beehives new European Union
the highest number ever notified by the
Member States to the European Commission
so those of you people who say that we
are you know reducing the number of
beehives the number of bees are
available I will see when a Commission
report is published in the next month
that this is not true in respect of rice
reports my enemy we have applied to
safeguard measure in respective indica
rice but of course some importers are
found aware and some exporters as well
from my anime I found a way to export
more different types of rice to the
European Union and still benefit from
the everything but arms trade
preferences so we have noted the
increase of imports of japonica rice
especially for my anime and this is was
the highest in the months of April and
May this year but in order to justify
any action that I might take and we need
to have more net more up-to-date data to
see as that trend continued Poland
accounts for a very small proportion of
total country maize imports about 1% the
EU mayors market is currently stable and
prices are in and around the same as
last year's average so we're looking at
the situation above what has happened
particularly with Ukraine but we see no
reason whatsoever to intervene in
America at the moment
we import 1.5 million tons amazed every
year so we need this product finally i
briefed the council on the recent
agreement between the EU or china and
geographical indications which i see
signed two weeks ago in beijing it's a
significant breakthrough in a number of
respects first of all it's the first GU
China trade agreement albeit in a great
trade and a modest one it's about GI is
only but it may mark a shift towards
Chinese interest in completing by the
end of 2020 an EU China Investment
agreement hopefully it's sending a good
sign we protected 100 names in each side
and over the four-year next four years
they they can add up to 175 further
names on each side it's an important
market for the European Union and China
accounts for 11 billion euro our exports
in agri-food
so it's an expanding market and
hopefully the GI agreement will be able
to focus on the policy food and drink
products that we have in the European
Union for the growing midlands
population which should reach more than
500 million people in the next three
years so again without tempting fate can
I thank you mr. president and the
finished presidency if we have great
cooperation during the last few months
and to thank you the media for your
courtesy your professionalism over the
last five years thank you Thank You
commissioner so as always the first now
open for